something I don't hear talked about
nearly enough is how different the Super
Saiyan Aura looked in the Dragon Ball
Manga the anime really took some
creative liberties with it in the manga
the Super Saiyan Aura was often shown as
very fire likee like a film of fire
engulfing its user whereas the anime
depicted the auras with those trademark
jaggies hatching lines in a mostly
uniform pattern I mean it looks good but
the more fire-like appearance of the
manga really stayed around pretty much
forever only really getting more Jagged
for Super Saiyan 2 and becoming full on
crazy with Super Saiyan 3 is it
necessarily A Bad Thing the way the
anime handled these oras no not really
but I do think the details of how the
auras changed as the forms went on is a
really neat one and one that I would
have loved to have seen adapted in the
anime proper cuz it tells its own story
about the forms themselves but whatever
it's just another reason for everyone to
read the Manga